foreign
Jared is with us in Minneapolis so we'll
be up there next week to see you guys
hey Jared how are you
good how are you doing better than I
deserve how can we help
hey I got a question about a I got a
small business
um I got two trucks
and um it seems like every time I get
caught up
um I got another big bill that I can't
cover
so then I'd put it on a credit card and
I just kind of feel like I'm stuck in a
loop
foreign
what kind of business are you in
the towing company
say again I'm salvage cars towing Towing
okay so you have two tow trucks yep okay
yep so you just
um like most people maybe even like me
got up uh and just decided
I'm in business today
um I've been working in the business for
like 12 years working is different than
running it
yep
and so now you now tote operating a tow
truck is no longer your job your job now
is running a business and you're really
good at operating a tow truck and now
you're having to learn how to run a
business is that fair
yep yeah okay so what kind of big bills
are coming up
unexpected
I got a it's a higher mileage truck so I
just had a turbo come go out on me it's
about 8 900 with the intercooler
and I'm hoping to put about two grand
down but I don't have enough to cover
the rest of the bill
okay
who's driving the other truck
um it's just me they got um you have two
trucks and you just shoot
yes park it till you make the money
with the other truck
okay what's the other bills you've come
up unexpectedly
I mean it's just bigger repairs that
they just seem like you got like six or
eight a year it seems like okay
I would think that that's not really
unexpected that's predictable
okay I think you're gonna have X number
of thousands of dollars average per
month some months none some months
double
of repairs because you've got a fleet of
trucks two trucks on the road and um
Towing stuff's hard on trucks
okay so you're gonna have repairs it's
part of your business model
okay I guess what I'm afraid of is if a
motor goes you know it's like 30 grand
to get it rebuilt do I get rid of the
truck or do I just just expect it to be
coming up and save up for it exactly
I don't think it's if a motor goes I
think it's when it goes
yep it's gonna go
it's part of your business you're going
to wear out these vehicles you're going
to have small repairs medium repairs and
huge repairs and Replacements these are
part of your business model and setting
money aside to keep all of that running
like paying the rent for a restaurant or
paying a worker that works there you've
got to set it aside out of here you've
been just making the money taking it all
home and maybe paying your taxes
yeah well I pay myself out of it too I
pay myself about 40 Grand a year that's
what I mean you're taking all the money
home there's no money laying down the
office
yes so you're just making the money and
taking it home you're treating it like
you have no expenses hardly other than
Fuel and insurance you're paying some of
that but
um yeah so uh
my guess is you're probably not charging
enough
okay they are set rates for the most
part which isn't kind of sucks dude set
rates by who
um they're mostly Insurance cars oh okay
insurance companies setting the right
yes sometimes you bet on them but for
the most part they're set okay
all right I'd be looking at my business
model because fuel's gone up repairs
have gone up everything's gone up and if
the insurance rate set rate doesn't go
up that might not be the business I want
to be in I may want to be in a a
non-insurance towing business or
something I don't know but you got to be
looking at all of that all the time
bottom line is though you need to be
running a profit loss statement I'd have
you sit down go to ramseysolutions.com
click on tax ELP and find someone that's
in the bookkeeping and accounting
business in your area that we recommend
have them start to help you build an
accounting system it's really not rocket
science it sounds intimidating but it's
not it's what you've got coming in minus
money set aside for repairs minus money
set aside for fuel minus money set aside
for uh insurance
and help you look at the pricing and
seeing you know can I afford to do this
you might be losing money on every tow
if if uh repair costs and insurance
costs and fuel costs have gone up so
much that by the time you you go over
there you're losing money every time
that could happen in the world we live
in today with this inflationary market
and this Fuel and Diesel's gone nuts too
so and factoring in the repairs like if
you do all of that and do your project
for the month to see yeah the actual
repairs because
um
you don't want to live behind the eight
ball which is where you are you're
always behind you're you're always
waiting on the next thing to happen
instead of planning for it to happen and
so uh Jared in the real estate business
uh back in the day when I was a a young
guy they taught us if you own an
apartment complex to say okay uh the the
roof has five years of life left on it
before it starts leaking and so I need
to figure out what a roof costs and I
need to put one-fifth of the roof cost
away for the next five years
to replace the roof plan to replace the
roof and we called those a sinking fund
uh that's what's called in that world
but in in your sense you need a sinking
fund to replace trucks and to do big
repairs to trucks and you need a budget
line item for minor repairs to trucks
and for a budget line item for fuel and
a budget line item for these things and
you need to put all the stuff together
and then that helps you calculate what
each trip costs and whether or not it
makes sense to do some of these trips
and and it helps you save up and fix
this one turbo right here as fast as you
can because you're going to put a big
old line item in there and um you know
you're gonna you're gonna work extra
you're gonna do everything you can to
get extra money coming in to cover this
right now but no I'm not going to tell
you to go into debt to do that I'm gonna
Park that truck and run the other truck
until I can do it it's what I would do
if I own the business and it's how I've
run this business too I started it on a
card table in my living room and we've
never borrowed a dime all the way out
hang on I'm going to send you a copy of
our book entree leadership which will
help you run your business it's what we
teach how we teach small business people
to run their business you're doing a
good job you're doing better than you
think you're doing but you've got to get
around in front of this because this is
causing a ton of stress for you that is
that doesn't have to be there doesn't
have to be there but um
so folks what happens is what happened
with Jared and what I was accusing him
of not in a derogatory way but just
reading his mail is a lot of people
become good at a trade
I'm a good plumber I'm a good heating
and air guy I'm a good Carpenter I'm
good at cooking
I'm good at being a chef I'm good at
whatever and then they open a business
I'm a good real estate agent
and then they open a business I'm going
to own a real estate company with agents
working for me I'm going to open a
heating and air company with heating and
Airtex working for me and I'm going to
have trucks I'm going to open a towing
company and you become an accidental
leader
an accidental entrepreneur
but what we always the mistake all of us
make and I I've made the mistake too
even inside of the Ramsey business I've
made the mistake
um just because someone's good at a
certain discipline or a certain thing
that does not necessarily mean they're
good at leading a business to do that
thing business leadership and business
entrepreneurship is a different skill
set than working on heat and air
or than working or then doing computer
programming or then whatever so if I've
got a computer programmer that's an
excellent computer programmer it doesn't
necessarily mean they may be the best in
the building but it doesn't necessarily
mean they're a leader yeah of that area
because leadership is a different skill
set than computer programming and so
anytime you're in the small business
setting one of the moves you make is
from practitioner to owner you move from
your hands doing the work to also your
brain has to be controlling the numbers
around your hands doing the work and the
people that use their hands doing the
work and so you got to get up on top of
it and my friend Michael Gerber who
wrote the book e-myth which is a
wonderful book on this subject says to
work on your business not just in your
business yeah that's his phrase and it
is an absolutely
fabulous phrase and it's a good way to
look at this stuff entree leadership
will help you with all of that